Speaker 1: The next story today about Russian
prisons is that WNBA star Brittney Griner
has been sentenced to nine years in a
Russian jail for drug smuggling. Now,
remember, the drug smuggling was under
a gram of cannabis oil. American women's
basketball star Brittney Griner was convicted
of deliberately smuggling drugs into Russia,
sentenced to nine years in a case that is raising
concerns that she's being used as a political pawn
in Russia's war against Ukraine. The judge
delivered the sentence and fined Griner a
million rubles. That's about $16,000, she said
the court took into account Griner is partial
admission of guilt, remorse, state of health
and charitable activities. Prior to the verdict,
Griner apologized and asked for leniency. Quote, I
never meant to hurt anybody. I never meant to put
in jeopardy the Russian population. I never meant
to break any laws. Here, I made an honest mistake.
I hope that in your ruling that it doesn't end my
life here. I know everybody keeps talking about
political pawn and politics, but I hope that that
is far from this courtroom. I want to say again,
I had no intent on breaking any Russian laws.
I had no intent. I did not conspire or plan to
commit this crime. She's been there six months
already. She is accused was accused of trying to
smuggle less than a gram of cannabis oil in her
luggage. She pleaded guilty. And nine years now,
the U.S. State Department is continuing to say
that this is a wrongful detention. The Biden
administration is continuing to negotiate for
her release. And regardless of what she says,
it has become an explosive political situation.
Now, I want to take a step further on this,
something we mentioned on yesterday's bonus
show, and I'm going to mention it again.
There is a contingent of the pro authoritarian
right wing. That is reacting to progressives
like me saying this is an example of the way the
Russian justice system works. 99% conviction rate,
outrageous sentences for minor crimes, all these
different things. There's a group of right wingers
who sort of likes authoritarianism and also likes
the war on drugs. That is saying you hypocritical
progressives. You just want to criticize Putin and
Russia and you don't say anything about the fact
that here in the United States, we also imprison
people for cannabis. Don't you care about that?
Yes, I do. And I've been talking about that for
a decade. The fact that in the U.S. we are, I
believe, unjustly imprisoning people for cannabis
possession, minimum, we can go beyond possession
as well. That's not less of a problem because of
what's happening with Brittney Griner. Russia is a
different situation where the the entire picture
of the judicial system involves everything from
planted evidence, prosecutions, a decision made a
priori that this is someone we need to imprison,
let's create charges, and the trial
itself is a sham. And of course,
we have elements of that in the United States.
But in the United States, the main problem
is how we handle drug possession and so-called
drug crimes. And I'm against both. So don't come
to me with this. Oh, you're only talking about it
because it's an opportunity to criticize Russia.
Absolutely not. We criticize it here in
the United States as well. The dynamics
are different. So now the hope becomes a
political solution. I mean, at this point,
it doesn't seem as though the solution is going
to come from any other place. Let me know what
you think. You can find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. But extraordinarily disturbing news.
The David Pakman show is an independent, audience
supported program. You can sign up for membership
at Join Pack Mint.com. We do a daily extra show
for our members called The Bonus Show. We also
offer a commercial free audio and video feed of
the show for our members, and it's available way
earlier than it is to everybody
else. That's. There's nothing
better than getting the show
5 hours early. At least that's
what the kids these days. Tell me.
You can sign up at join Packman com.